anna darin sammelt alte flaschen ihren
job als krankenpflegerin hat sie
verloren dann noch einen autounfall und
die inflation hier in riverside county
kalifornien liegt bei zehn prozent um
die rechnungen zu zahlen muss anna ihren
schmuck verkaufen sie hat angst ich
will nicht bankrottgehen mein haus
verlieren meine unabhängigkeit oder das
bisschen moral dass ich noch habe um
meine rechnungen selbst zu bezahlen
viele amerikaner leiden auch deshalb
tritt die us notenbank jetzt auf die
inflationsbremse eine weitere erhöhung
der zinsen um einen dreiviertel punkt
auf bis zu 25
wir wollen mit unseren werkzeugen die
nachfrage an die verfügbare waren
angleichen um die inflation wieder auf
zwei prozent runter zu bringen und sie
langfristig dazu heißt
weniger verfügbares geld führt zu
weniger nachfrage mit der zinserhöhung
klettern auch die zinsen für kredite die
nachfrage nach autos häusern und anderen
gütern soll zurückgehen dadurch könnten
die preise weniger steigen vielleicht
sogar sinken aber die hoffnung birgt
auch ein risiko die
kalte feld so lady notenbank hin so
hinterher dass sich die inflation
verfestigt und ausgedehnt hat deshalb
wird der preisrückgang nicht stark genug
sein es gibt die sorge dass wir in eine
rezession gehen weil die notenbank der
entwicklung hinterher läuft
tatsächlich brummt derzeit die
amerikanische wirtschaft eine extrem
niedrige
arbeitslosenquote so viele offene
stellen dass viele amerikaner billigjobs
gegen besser bezahlte arbeitsplätze
tauschen können die us börse erwartet
offensichtlich dass die zinsentscheidung
wirkt ohne die konjunktur zu sehr zu
bremsen der dow jones legte erst mal
deutlich zu aber solange die preise noch
nicht sinken bleibt für energy randow
die hoffnung auf einen neuen job damit
sie nicht mehr angewiesen ist auf
gespendete lebensmittel wie so viele die
unter der inflation leiden
im kampf gegen die steigenden preise und
aus angst vor einem wirtschaftsabschwung
erhöht die us notenbank also erneut den
leitzins fragen wir nach bei mrt wissen
unserem studioleiter in washington
erstmals schönen guten morgen jedenfalls
aus unserer sicht wie wird das denn mit
der erhöhung des leitzins in den usa
aufgenommen
also zuerst mal positiv die reaktion der
börse sprach dafür aber das kann sich
heute schon wieder ändern denn heute
kommen die neuesten wirtschaftszahlen
raus zum zweiten quartal
oder ist natürlich immer die große frage
ob es erste anzeichen gibt dass amerika
in eine rezession schlittert und das
wäre natürlich schlecht für die ganze
welt das ist ja ein spagat man muss
einerseits die inflation abbremsen aber
darf die konjunktur nicht abwürgen und
deswegen wird auch die politik hier
aktiv es gibt für joe biden an diesem
donnerstag eine sehr gute nachricht
nämlich dass mit hoher
wahrscheinlichkeit auch in der zweiten
kammer des kongresses dem
repräsentantenhaus ein paket
verabschiedet wird über
280 milliarden dollar das ist förderung
für die hochtechnologie industrie für
forschung und entwicklung darunter
allein 52 milliarden für halbleiter
mikro chip hersteller und ein zweites
riesiges paket ist in der mache da hat
man sich offenbar jetzt geeinigt das
könnte in den nächsten wochen nachkommen
500 milliarden dollar noch einmal oben
drauf da geht es um den kampf gegen den
klimawandel um erneuerbare energien um
auch gesundheitspolitik das spielen
zuschüsse eine große rolle also im
grunde genommen auch um die preise
dadurch etwas zu senken und das tut man
natürlich eben in der hoffnung dass die
konjunktur dann weiter läuft das neue
jobs entstehen aber es ist eine
gratwanderung über die nächsten monate
500 milliarden 280 milliarden wo kann
man da nur sagen woche immer das geld
herkommen soll elmar welche konsequenzen
wir gerade schon die ganze welt
angesprochen hat denn diese zinserhöhung
über diesen us tellerrand hinaus
ja vielleicht noch kurz vorweg dass
tatsächlich die gegenfinanzierung für
diese riesen pakete auch aus
steuereinnahmen kommen sollen da gibt es
nämlich dann steuer mindeststeuern auf
unternehmen auf große konzerne auch das
ist ein wichtiger punkt hier aber
tatsächlich hat das ganze natürlich
auswirkungen auf den rest der welt wenn
hier die zinsen weiter steigen bedeutet
dass das kapital allen voran natürlich
der dollar in aller welt in richtung usa
fließt dadurch wird der dollar ein stück
weit stärker das heißt für länder in der
welt allen voran den schwellenländern zb
die türkei brasilien argentinien und
anderen für die wird es teurer werden
weil sie vieles eben in dollar bezahlen
müssen und wenn sie sich geld leihen
wollen auch das wird für sie teurer und
das ist für wirtschaft natürlich auch
schwierig und dazu dadurch entsteht ein
druck auf die notenbanken weltweit auf
die zentralbanken ebenfalls die zinsen
zu erhöhen um eben ein stück weit die
inflation abzubremsen auch auf die ezb
entsteht dieser druck ganz massiv und
ländern alle mitziehen dann gibt es
zumindest die chance das ist die leser
der in den usa die inflation weltweit
ein stückweit auszubremsen die
lieferketten zu entlasten und dann doch
die wirtschaft weiterhin auf kurs zu
halten sagt elmar theveßen vielen
herzlichen dank dafür nach washington
unser studioleiter dort zur erhöhung des
leitzinses durch die us-notenbank danke
dir